[Musique]
alors vous savez ma été nous sommes en
gascogne quand on découvre la gasconne
on s'aperçoit qu'une région de tradition
une tradition qui existait déjà à
l'époque des mousquetaires qui viennent
12 d'ici là pour affronter les
péripéties de la vie
pour commencer une bonne omelette et
d'après ce que ça va mieux alors comme
remède à notre mélancolie de l'instant
on va faire des omelettes
bientôt on va faire d'abord le net au
sein oui le moule est plutôt girondine
windows m ensuite on fera peut-être une
omelette on dit si les girolles jessen
les chanterelles et c'est plutôt la
seelandaise sur briand frein on fera le
maître truffe oui ça c'est le maître du
périgord voilà voilà alors on va
commencer peut-être aussi très bien
alors on va découper
quand même un peu les mrc tous nous
avons montré précédemment composer les
utiliser frais bien sûr mais je les
trouvais sur les marchés les utiliser en
conserve bien sûr alors de toute manière
vous les couper vous avez fait chauffer
de lui de l'huile pas ce que je vais
faire cuire à la friteuse et après j'ai
montré c'est mieux parce qu'ils gonflent
ils sont dus sept écluses mieux et sont
moins graisseux je l'aimais maintenant
dans la friteuse du de bière chaude
faisons bien d'enfler
il est en travaux cinq minutes
ça là pendant ce temps et on n'a
évidemment pas vous y avait là on va
passer par les préparer les yeux voilà
on va percer les regards par contre
seules trois communes abandonné oui
alors là nous allons faire une omelette
de personnes de personnes pour 200
mètres 6e oui celle sa vie pour avoir
bien sûr toujours toujours toujours la
rue sel poivre plutôt cocasse et du
poivre faire là bas pas de vous ça vous
n'aimez pas loin non et honda est ce
bien bière et une cotation matures on va
y ajouter un soupçon de l'e commerce
alors beaucoup plus belle on n'est pas
favori et champion suprême invités ils
sont prêts ce qu'on fait alors on les
écoute on va sortir de ceci ou cela
friteuse et on les met dans une poêle
chaude
voyez bien accepte oui voilà on est
on les savait et on et pouvoir bien
entendu et poivrez on y met la
persillade
la voilà que voici autrement dit haye et
paraiba ch et au hachoir pour que soient
pas de la wii très anciens substance
veut beaucoup plus est après avoir
enlevé le germe de l'ail très important
ici j'ai reçu quelques uns disent yes
voilà la fois les choses les champignons
voyez ils sont beaucoup plus sec plus
jolie oui oui champignons cuits dans la
pétole et nous vous en sommes honnêtes
voilà on veut pas un petit peu et voilà
alors la raison monette
il y en a qui les aiment barbe d'autres
qui lèchent ceux qui les aiment sèche
les retourne dans une assiette répond
cure dessous et les autres on les roule
est une figure comme ça c'est tout comme
communaux maintenant val et bien pendant
quelques ion pourrait faire les girolles
alors oui à la lécithine jeu bien sûr
alors comment faites vous avec les
girolles les girolles pas la friteuse à
la poêle
bon alors là pour les choses là pour les
chaudes on va y mettre un peu de graisse
est toujours mon éternel grèce tiercé
pour lire de la grèce de la grèce ou de
ghajar audois ce qu'on veut ce qu'on a
sous la main on va la mettre bien là on
va mettre nos girolles parce que les
giros des girondins conservent donc
elles sont déjà cuites en il faut pas
laisser cuire très longtemps où il va on
trouve pas toujours l'intention des
frères explique exactement oui voilà on
va les mettre
nous allons lessard et les poivrons et
en même temps a ajouté de la personne
adversaire dans un moment dans un an on
va les faire revenir quand même nicolas
de faire revenir bien aussi il faut
quand même que la cuisse au moins au
moins cinq minutes la sec 5 10 minutes
ah oui quand même nom va le faire bien
revenir
nous mettrons à merci avec interviennent
doré s pas bon et n'a pas non sans avoir
fêté un peu nauséeux jo et accélérer un
peu de feu bien sûr que je vais vous
donner oui tout en même temps les
horizons saler poivrer
et elles sont données sur colombes
n'était pas beaucoup plus légères retour
y ait un peu de girone quadrillé c'est
bien la mouture nous sommes bien oui oui
mais c'est un mot qu'on peut dire
partout vendredi partout rebuts et aux
fouilles je savais bien sentis salis
bien ce que ça veut dire
la voyait santé joly il ne faut pas les
couper on les laisse entière parce que
déjà que ceux des forts sont à l'essai
pour les erreurs pour les mrc d'indiquer
les migrant-es entière même quand elles
sont fraîches
rien ne sert de miroir non oui sûr mais
il ya une saison en fin de saison
en réprimant dehors comme romario âmes
par amoussou a laissé revenir un tout
petit peu plus là
maintenant on va y mettre notre
persillade que voilà que voilà partout
et ça les arrange et on va la laisser
cuire une minute la persillade avec le
mal est bien allier lianhai et bien
merci voilà dessus à la mère de
préférence si on veut la conserver au
moins si on veut employer tout de suite
oui en collatéraux à choix mais quand
même espérer plus aujourd'hui à la main
ça semble ouvrir bien souvent et on va
faire notre bonheur
maintenant voilà il pendant qu'elle va
cuire et bien on va commencer à
réfléchir à la plus belle la lettre une
omelette aux truffes bien sûr alors ça
nous allons la ferme
voilà les truffes et on va commencer par
les mrc
on y va on va déprendre toute semaine ou
tout à tout petits morceaux
c'est le passé 2 les vrais cuisiniers
fonctionne mieux que moi moche et pas
une vraie cuisinière et nous la cuisine
comme la mesure où commence à me dire
voilà
et alors on peut les faire soit en lui
le sauveur nous on va les faire leur
beurre liquid pour les cuirs bon parce
que vous les fait revenir un petit peu
quand même un peu à la fois
vous voilà maintenant on va prendre la
poêle que voici
on va y mettre un petit peu de beurre la
formule un peu plus pour bien mouillé la
poêle
oui
c'est refondre notre idée que ce soit
fondu normalement mais dans une poêle
bien chaude et voici alors on va prendre
notre us nous allons les mettre dans la
poêle sur la lame la wii mauvais 17e
la voix leur laisse méditer faut pas
perdre ces précieux la truffe c'est très
cher voilà c'est le champignon noble ça
par excellence n'avait pas les départs
sur la truffe de conditionneurs de
cuisine de dumas voilà ça y est là ça
suffit on va mettre roberto tout de
suite
la voilà régulière alors je ne salez
poivrez salez poivrez la forêt n'est
rien que de beurre et au bureau bonheur
va permettre beaucoup pour quoi que ce
soit il ya la trouver oui pour que ça
ait goût quand même bien oui parce que
ça suffit
voilà là et on va laisser cuire et
pendant ce temps on va attaquer une
autre m est visionnable silom l'aide
qu'on appelle la moulette sarladaise 100
à 2 exactement
maïté pour 7 m qu'est ce qu'il faut il
faut tout d'abord des pommes de terre
oui que voici qu'on a déjà fait faucher
friperie alors qu'on met dans la poêle
évidemment et qu'est-ce que vous avez
mis dans votre poêle avait toujours
toujours la grèce - de la grèce de
jojoba grèce de la part bien sûr de doha
de cranach comme on veut bon et après
voici le concept on a fait revenir je
les écoute ou hier des commissions beau
oui ne vous a fait revenir qu'est ce
qu'ils avaient dans la cocotte la grèce
aussi de l'akazu canard toujours de la
grèce c'est pas riche en calories
toujours de la grèce je remets mais
c'est là je mélange de tous viens je
vais large comme ceux ci ça fait une
omelette très avantageuses par die n'est
pas de donnions les échalotes nature
comme ça oui
on appelle ça une égalité aux
forestières chez nous aussi oui alors là
je vais du sel du poivre bien sur wii
salez et poivrez
je remuais de tous
on essaie bien de prendre le sel poivre
aux champignons et aux pommes de terre
oui je maintenant je vais ajouter la
persillade
la voilà mon idée que voilà où il ya de
l'ail et du persil bien sûr bien sûr
bien ça assez abondamment voici et je
remets encore pour bien mélanger et moi
je vous apporte les eaux pendant ce
temps voilà bien mousseux oui ya battu
avec un dérivé de l'est allez-y voilà
vous avez les versets là dessus je vais
accélérer un petit peu le feu oui et on
va le mettre
comme tout est chaud on va mettre tous
ceux là dessus ça grésille bien et en
plus on est les trois personnes 3 par
personne
et là il ya une omelette revient pour sa
personne car les personnes y en a été
hélas nous terminons cette série
d'émissions ce avons terminé avec des
hommes des régionales c'est certain
qu'on aurait pu faire beaucoup d'autres
choses beaucoup d'autres zones et
régionales comme la touche opinion on
aurait pu faire autre chose avec les
champignons ça pour aujourd'hui nous
avions c'est l'omelette au trail qu'on
appelle ici l'omelette aux girolles
c'est l'homme laddh typiquement maronèse
d'avion c'est l'omelette aux cèpes bien
parti avec la persillade
oui ça c'est plutôt les girondines on
peut dire dans fait l'objet d'autres us
lassé périgourdin alors été truffe est
évident qu'on peut faire aussi beaucoup
d'autres choses et puis l'homme led
classiques l'omelette dit sarnez qui
cumule la pomme de terre frites dont
sommes frites au gras de canard gras de
canard et laissait davantage aux rares
on pourrait faire tellement de choses
qu'il faut espérer qu'on travers
j'espère sale affaire là est en tout cas
eh bien vous espérons beaucoup de
recettes de cuisine régionale en
formalité avec chaque au revoir à tous
à bientôt peut-être et à bientôt
[Musique]